allez ce soir on reçoit l'un des plus
grands noms du cinéma français et ces
musiques de films légendaire il est le
compositeur de près de 500 musique de
films on regarde un recap de son
parcours exceptionnel avant d'accueillir
mesdames et messieurs monsieur monsieur
vladimir Cosma
il est sans aucun doute l'un des plus
grands compositeurs de sa génération
bonjour vladimir Cosma on dit que je
suis le plus grand oui en quoi en talent
bien sûr puisque le chef d'orchestre
encore ou moins a réalisé pléthore de
musique pour le 7e art 500 musique de
films composés par vous dont certaines
qui étaient la banque sont immenses
succès populaire comme Rabbi Jacob la
boum l'As des As ou encore le dîner de
cons à 83 ans le compositeur a décidé de
rembobiner le fil de son immense et très
longue carrière en donnant trois
concerts exceptionnels au Grand Rex à
Paris intitulé vladimir Cosma ses
inoubliables musiques de films
il sera accompagné d'un orchestre
philharmonique composé de plus de 130
personnes
[Musique]
ces inoubliables musiques de films
prennent une toute autre dimension en
live
et garde une saveur particulière pour
chacun d'entre nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vladimir Cosma tellement heureux de vous
revoir j'ai eu le plaisir de vous
accueillir déjà plusieurs fois et ça me
fait très plaisir de vous revoir on est
tous très admiratifs mon cher Vladimir
vous le savez alors quelques chiffres
vous permettez vous allez être très
touché plus de 50 ans de carrière plus
de 500 musiques de films 29 millions de
disques vendus notamment pour reality de
César de la meilleure musique de films
diva et le bal exact le bal des
torrescolas une merveille où il y a pas
un mot il y a que de la musique je le
rappelle de cette heure de la meilleure
musique pour la télévision on applaudi
encore monsieur vladimir Cosma
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous mon cher
Vladimir vraiment merci beaucoup quand
on sort tous ces chiffres Vladimir on
regarde les affiches là regardez tout
autre vie
c'est la mienne aussi
en même temps ça oui voilà c'est ça vous
fout le tournis un peu mais c'est comme
ça je
conteste pas quoi il a toujours beaucoup
d'humilité
voilà on va s'occuper de vous vous allez
voir bon les amis oui oui alors parce
que ça c'est exceptionnel tout le monde
les connaît d'ailleurs je vous proposer
un petit coup est dans quelques instants
parce que je veux écouter des musiques
les amis vous ne jouez pas Vladimir
vous ne jouez pas ce sont nos amis qui
doivent retrouver le film de votre
musique après on va vous demander
comment vous préparer une musique de
film si c'est avant si c'est après si
c'est pendant ça ça nous intéresse et si
on peut déjà prévoir selon la qualité du
film ça va être un succès ou pas etc
vous nous direz toutes ces petits
secrets de fabrication mais pour le
moment allez un premier titre à
découvrir attention de souffle pas dans
le public
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas la chèvre
allez c'est bien vous avez reconnu
Vladimir
vous savez au début
la musique qui me accompagnait toujours
mon personnage c'était le grand blanc
avec une chaussure noire et puis petit à
petit la chèvre a fait son chemin est
arrivé et j'ai vu sur RTL tout d'un coup
un classement ou la chèvre passait
devant le grand blond c'était étonnant
il y a une espèce de concurrence comme
ça entre les titres après l'autre
revenait etc enfin deuxième titre à
découvrir
[Musique]
ça c'est magique attention un peu de
la flexible
[Applaudissements]
de Marcel Pagnol c'est d'oeuvre la
musique bouleversante qui va
parfaitement avec l'histoire c'est
magnifique comment vous avez travaillé
justement cette musique est un peu
différente de ce que vous faites est un
peu différent parce que j'ai essayé
d'éviter de faire une musique
méditerranéenne provençale typique avec
des filtres avec des tambourins des
choses comme ça donc j'ai trouvé
fallait aller dans le contraste d'une
nuit très lyrique très très émouvante et
voilà c'est ça la saga bravo allez un
autre titre mes amis ne trichent pas
c'est dur bah oui c'est dur
[Applaudissements]
clavier et à votre avis qui c'est qui
chante
il a accepté tout de suite Guy Marchand
de chanter cette chanson
de chanter c'était lui déjà vous pensiez
à lui directement pour cette chanson
donc c'était obligatoire comme c'est un
chanteur aussi mais lui il pensait qu'il
va jouer une musique de jazz oui parce
qu'il n'aime pas il n'aime pas la
musique de variété alors quand il a vu
que c'est une un slow de variété il
était très déçu
préfère le jazz il préférait le jazz le
Congo etc donc on a eu quelques
contradictions au niveau de de
l'interprétation de la musique en tout
cas c'est très très réussi allez à notre
titre plus difficile
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça aurait pu c'est parti
au Paradis non la Grande Vadrouille
on a tous les deux
Astérix c'est la surprise de César
Vladimir mais vous avez arrêté la
musique juste comme il y avait le mot
Astérix
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est plus difficile d'écrire
pour une bande dessinée comme ça non non
pour moi c'est pas pareil
pour une symphonie pour une chanson pour
du jazz
c'est ce qui sort de soi l'inspiration
ce que le bon Dieu vous apporte comme
cadeau qui compte j'ai une question à
Monsieur Cosma toute Monique de film
vous les avez faites après avoir vu les
images ou parfois on vous demande des
musiques en même temps que j'allais
demander si tu veux
pas tout de suite mais tu sais quoi on
va le faire mais pour le moment on va
écouter on va écouter cette musique
[Musique]
évidemment
regardez c'est magique
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup travaillé avec Jean-Paul
Belmondo beaucoup oui je l'ai connu et
très gentil très et là c'est ça c'était
un moment émouvant pour moi et ce que
c'est pas moi qui devait faire la
musique obligatoirement j'étais en
concurrence avec Ennio Morricone et on a
fait des maquettes chacun et finalement
la mienne a été choisie et ça a été ça a
été
une belle rencontre avec Gérard Oury et
avec
Jean-Paul Belmondo et justement Gérard
Oury qui est je le rappelle le papa de
Daniel Thompson qu'on a évoqué tout à
l'heure est-ce qu'il a c'est facile de
vous imposer sur un film par exemple
vous venez de citer il y a Ennio
Morricone il y a francisley c'était un
grand Michel Legrand ça a été facile
pour vous de
jamais facile la bagarre une bagarre
professionnelle il y a une bagarre
relationnelle il y a tout tout ce que
vous voulez tout ce que vous pouvez
imaginer là-dedans ce n'est jamais donné
d'avance n'est jamais gagné d'avance et
alors là votre plus grand succès il faut
dire quand même vladimir Cosma Dieu sait
que toutes ces chansons ces musiques on
les connaît on les a dans la tête c'est
notre histoire reality
ça voilà ça comment c'est arrivé est-ce
que vous ce succès énorme
[Musique]
j'imaginais si peu
au début j'ai failli refuser de faire la
musique pourquoi puisque c'était un
petit film sans vedette sans vedette
ce film là je faisais l'inspecteur la
bavure je faisais le goût du parapluie
j'avais des grosses commandes et je me
suis dit encore un film pour les jeunes
tout ça donc j'ai dit non un quart
d'heure plus tard Monsieur Alain Poiret
qui était le grand manitou de la Gaumont
appelé monsieur Cosma vous ne pouvez pas
faire à la Gaumont que les films avec
Belmondo ou avec des Funès etc pour une
fois qu'on a besoin de vous pour faire
une musique pour un playback qu'on va
enregistrer dans une semaine je vous
prie faites-le c'était un ordre c'était
même pas une demande donc j'ai dit
d'accord monsieur et j'ai fait la
musique je l'ai envoyé 4 jours plus tard
et ça a été pris et ça a été tourné la
scène où les jeunes danser voilà il
jouait il dansait sur ma sur ma maquette
et alors c'est vous qui avez choisi
Richard Sanderson qui chante c'est moi
qui ai choisi de chercher un
anti-crôleur un anti je cherche un
chanteur qui n'est pas de voix
un chanteur qui tout d'un coup il en
faisait des tonnes etc je sais quelqu'un
qui devient la voix du film la voix de
Sophie Marceau qu'elle rêve et donc un
jour je suis tombé sur la sur Richard
Sanderson qui était complètement
inconnue qui était un choristes et je me
suis dit voilà c'est ce qu'il me faut et
dans l'après-midi ils ont engagé pour
pour chanter alors cette belle musique
parce que j'ai bien emballé moi sur
cette
que vous empocheriez près de 250 000
euros par an ne répondez pas grâce à
cette à ce titre là donc il va répondre
tout de suite après vous revenez avec
nous c'était PMP people tout d'abord mon
cher baladimir juste avant la pause je
vous ai posé une question peut-être vous
paraît-elle indiscrète mais j'aimerais
tout de même connaître la réponse il
paraît que reality la chanson de la boum
que tout le monde connaît ils en train
de danser ils ont même danser pendant la
pub
on va la mettre un peu parce que
regardez les filles ça y est elles y
sont
[Musique]
pas des meilleurs
est-ce vrai que cela vous rapporte plus
de 250 000 € par an et goûter d'abord
vous m'avez dit que je suis pas obligé
de répondre mais je vois
je ne vois pas pourquoi c'est pas
honteuse de répondre ou de parler
d'argent de son travail ça me semble pas
beaucoup mais c'est oui c'est vrai pour
c'est une des chansons mais ça fait
combien de temps que ça dure l'histoire
mais ça dure c'est une des chansons qui
qui est le plus joué au monde
donc qu'est-ce que c'est un football un
joueur de football ou un grand dix fois
plus que ça pour une journée
Patrick Hernandez aussi c'est pareil
il faut ajouter les autres qui sont
rejoués et tout donc ça s'accumule en
fin d'année c'est quoi
ça commence à devenir intéressant
je me disais que je trouve que vous
faites partie de l'un des seuls qui a un
peu entre guillemets vulgarisé la
musique classique vous avez même fait
des chansons pour pour la boum comment
est-ce que vos collègues de la du milieu
un peu classique
si vous regardez quand ils vous ont vu
faire des musiques pour des chips comme
ça au début c'était avec beaucoup de
mépris c'est-à-dire on me disait bon
d'accord tu fais des musiques pour de
Funès pour Pierre Richard pour tout ça
mais pour toi qu'est-ce que tu fais pour
toi pour ta vie comme si c'était une
musique alimentaire alors que c'était
pas du tout le cas je faisais pour moi
pour mon plaisir et il se fait que ça ça
a eu beaucoup de succès que ça a eu
beaucoup mais c'était pas fait dans le
but de faire de l'argent ou de faire
tout ça c'était dans le but de faire de
la musique alors justement ce qui est
intéressant maintenant de savoir c'est
comment ça se passe comment vous
composez la musique est-ce que parce que
c'est selon les compositeurs c'est un
peu différent voyez j'ai reçu Claude
leloucher récemment lui il me disait que
la musique de film était un acteur
presque un acteur principal dans le film
et qu'il faisait la musique en amont
avec Francis Lay avec Michel Legrand
avec tout tous les hommes avec lesquels
il a travaillé ou Barbelivien même et
vous comment vous travaillez alors on
vous donne le film vous le faites avant
on vous donne on vous donne l'histoire
racontez-nous mais écoutez je le fais de
toutes les façons possibles avant vous
avez vous avez cité le film Le bal et
bien le bal c'est un film dont j'ai fait
la musique alors qu'elle était déjà
composée par Armand de travail au lit et
refusé par les par les producteurs du
film par les distributeurs et on est
venu chez moi pour refaire une nouvelle
musique sur le même film donc c'était un
cas particulier mais
je fais parfois de la musique sans voir
du tout le film un metteur en scène qui
me raconte l'histoire
il me dit ce qu'il veut dire dans le
film et je vais chez moi et je commence
à écrire quelques notes de musique je
vais vous dire un secret j'ai depuis que
je suis petit j'ai un professeur de
musique qui m'a qui m'a dit écoute
n'écris pas quand tu as un thème quand
tu as quelques notes ne les écris pas
sur des feuilles volantes parce que tu
vas les perdre construis toi des gros
cahiers de musique cartonné et quand tu
as quelque chose en tête d'int tu
marques tout dedans comme ça tu vas les
garder tu vas jamais les perdre et ça a
été pour moi un conseil
essentiel essentiel les musiques sont
quand même différentes par exemple quand
on vous donne le titre par exemple de la
zizanie que vous avez composé également
avec on le rappelle à nigerardo et et
lui de Funès forcément la zizanie il
fallait que la musique soit très enlevée
très bien
ouais plus nerveuse du plat boom quoi
c'est des questions de rythme et tout ça
mais ça c'est un peu de la cuisine
musicale mais le fond le fond musical on
parle des éléments de musique qui ne
sont pas au début pour comme des comme
une musique je ne sais pas de musique
descriptive je ne fais pas une musique
qui décrit la scène du film c'est qu'on
voit des voitures qui courent la musique
elle doit courir forcément ceci dit je
fais un thème qui me semble intéressant
pour le film dans son ensemble et après
quand les scènes en question arrivent la
poursuite de voiture
après c'est ça je les adapte je les
réorganise alors dites-moi Vladimir
alors vous qui avez toutes ces musiques
avec toutes ces stars incroyables
Belmondo Louis de Funès Annie Girardot
tout le monde vous avez tout le monde et
notamment Pierre Richard Pierre Richard
surtout je crois que la musique les
musiques de Pierre Richardson sont
étroitement associées à sa carrière quel
rapport vous avez vécu vous êtes devenu
amis avec des personnalités comme
celle-là c'est des amitiés
professionnels c'est pas des amis on est
amis avec ces ces ces camarades de
classe quand on est jeune tout ça après
on connaît les gens dans du métier ça
devient des des amitiés professionnelles
bonne bon rapport moins bon mais c'est
pas de la vraie amitié les amitiés
circonstances sur le moment voilà donc
avec Pierre Richard je suis toujours en
très bon terme on a j'ai fait
pratiquement tous ces films j'ai fait je
sais pas 13 15 films avec Pierre Richard
tous les films de Pierre Richard qui ont
marché chez vous c'est pour ça que j'ai
dit c'est étroitement associé
Jean-Michel j'imagine que ces variables
en fonction des films et ça vous prend
combien de temps moyenne pour par
exemple pour la chef pour écrire la
musique de la chef combien de temps ça
vous a pris écoutez pour la écrire la
musique de la chèvre ça m'a pris toute
une vie parce que si vous laissez le
temps de l'écriture technique du thème
etc mais c'est tout le reste tant de ma
vie ou c'était thème là mon travail je
les ai fait je l'ai construite je les
refaites le thème de la serre je l'ai
fait au moins en 15 fois ou 20 fois dans
les versions différentes que j'ai dans
mes cahiers ouais si on veut chercher
l'historique de tout ça on trouve c'est
un réel travail et votre musique
préférée c'est laquelle de laquelle de
vos musiques préférées ça c'est
différent ça dépend des jours là
aujourd'hui on est samedi aujourd'hui
c'est laquelle écoutez vous m'avez
tellement parlé de la boum que je suis
ben oui mais nous aussi on a beaucoup
est-ce que vous avez déjà refusé de
faire la musique d'un film et pourquoi
oui j'ai refusé
bêtement de faire la musique de la
septième compagnie
pourquoi parce que je venais de faire le
Rabbi Jacob et on m'avait catalogué déjà
comme compositeur de musique de comédie
et je ne voulais pas que mon nom soit
accolé uniquement à des comédies je me
dis bon j'ai fait la mise à top
maintenant je vais plus bas de deux
Funès je passe à 7e compagnie des
refuser donc quand vous entendez quand
vous entendez ce que ça a donné de la
musique de la septième compagnie ça vous
vous dites ils ont bien bossé ils ont
bien bossé le c'est quand même une
musique très reconnaissable d'abord je
n'écoute pas forcément je me rappelle
pas de la 7e compagnie je peux pas vous
répondre
ma culture ma culture ne se fait pas
j'écoute les les chansons qui me
plaisent des symphonies des choses comme
ça les écoute pas forcément tous des
musiques de films qui sont faites je
l'ai pas fait j'ai loupé cette affaire
entre guillemets je regrette et puis
c'est un point c'est tout ça va pas plus
loin allez les amis trois concerts
exceptionnels au Grand Rex si vous
voulez passer des soirées divines le
vendredi 16 juin à 20h le samedi 17 juin
à 20h le dimanche 18h à 15h au Grand Rex
monsieur vladimir Cosma merci un grand
bonheur un grand bonheur ça va aussi un
grand honneur
merci
on regarde
[Musique]
inutile gris ou de pleurer
et de grands artistes que vous retrouvez
sur la scène aussi Vladimir vous savez
que c'est toujours un grand bonheur de
vous accueillir je suis ravi bravo
beaucoup d'admiration pour vous bravo
merci beaucoup allez